oh honey honey what look is that
Dhalsim yeah I think there's dhalsim
that's not dhalsim that's just some
Indian go you're racist racist yeah it's
cuz he's really not because it's
fictional arms you sick freak races
you're racist
Dhalsim it's me Jenny oh okay
no it's Ryu huh come on Ned you know me
sure you can Ryu but put yourself round
no in a big round hair honey clearly
it's a drunk idiot man let's go he's
drunk you're sweating is
air-conditioning in here feelings I
don't have feelings my feelings don't
hurt at all it is what it is that's the
easy mistake in our twins Japanese
Japanese same piece easy mistake about
10 years ago that's funny you gonna do
this turn the camera guys that's friends
actually we are and you know I'm just
stating facts huh
fine let's say facts your face looks
like a mistake you got two pieces of
toilet paper on your head yeah well you
got some Adhan mittens for gloves that's
funny thing your mom bought it for me
in your face okay you know what your
this isn't a real black belt oh hey
that's funny right
no it's funny you know Dhalsim call me
honda cuz clearly drunk sorry sweetie
can we talk for a second yeah you know
you're fat right honey seriously
Trisha one yes we gained a couple of
pounds big deal cares about that it's
not the way it's you haven't been you I
mean when was the last time you oh and
what was the last time I would you Duke
and honey you haven't done any of those
moves you used to do the heavy going
crazy ah hadouken o hadouken o hadouken
right now if you want me to do can
hadouken your face off can't do it
hey man about the whole a Honda thing
yeah Juicin hi huh nothing ha ha yeah
anyways a dude hair grew out you look
way better by the way look completely
different
what are you been up to I'm a yoga
instructor now now take a deep breath
yoga you go wrong end it very nice hey
so you and Charlie are married huh yeah
yeah yeah love it first kick love at
first I do lookin what's wrong I don't
know I mean I mean you said yourself
when you first saw me you thought I was
a honda so straight up man I don't know
if I'd be able to do can even if I tried
hey you just need to gain a little
weight so I got confused you know I'm
sure you could still Hadouken if you
tried I want you to that's my wife look
okay you are definitely not a Honda I
just ran into him like 30 years ago he's
still huge running around in a big-ass
diaper he doesn't just look like a huge
fat baby
yeah I'm stomping around Sean say things
are made me laugh now you crazy dude is
he's always sweating really yeah okay
huge okay sumimasen oh my dude I Oh Dada
what did I oh D Honda what up it's not
that bad it's not that bad it's not that
bad
what is your Atkins okay listen you just
need to get your Hadouken back that's
how you pronounce it it is no hado no no
listen
ha ha ha we'll work on it
are you ready to start your new life
yeah know about this man cuz focus today
you get your Hadouken back
you
honey what come outside I have something
to show I'm busy no but you want to come
outside cuz I have something to show you
I'm 40 now huh
outside Oh what
yeah how do you like me now baby huh huh
why don't you go ahead now show me when
you're famous charlie hotcakes who can't
do it hey what is going on you two hope
you guys like that very special dating
game episode and ka Howie you got his
Hadouken back baby but check it out if
you guys want to go ahead and copy
yourself one of these new Street Fighter
5 games you can go ahead and check that
link in the description box below son
hope y'all enjoyed that video got more
sketches coming at you holla at your boy
Brad Brad Brad